the museum is a charity we have to find
ways of generating funds that keep us
going so what we do
commercially helps us do what we do for
education one of those were things that
we do is hire out some of our machines
to the world of TV and film
documentaries all that kind of stuff
eight live events even and make them do
things that the director of this program
might want them to do so this is where
the idea came from to be honest so we
were approached by if I remember rightly
somebody on Twitter I think Graham
Graham Linehan was looking for some
interesting props to put on the set for
the second series of the IT Crowd and
had just put a post out saying what
should I have there and somebody says
hey you should get computer museum to
supply some stuff and something I think
quite can't quite remember the rest of
the what happened but ultimately we were
in contact and we said oK we've got some
things we talked about some stuff but
then we said well actually if you had
something like that behind moss the
people that know are going to freak out
because it's quite a rare machine
they're gonna see that and go yeah but
that that just doesn't that would not
normally belong in a in an office like
that they love the idea and that's it it
was there though I think we had a victim
NZ there and a where as X 81 in a wooden
case all sorts of weirdness but that was
kind of a star and then all of a sudden
they started getting emails going isn't
that now Terry in the background in it
and so job done that's what it was there
for just that little nod to the Nerds
did you provide the Internet this gen
it's the Internet we didn't provide the
Internet in fact I tried to get the
internet from him and he wouldn't give
it to me
Sony's shelf still is that it is a
living room I think yeah he wouldn't do
it but I know the box that it was made
from well the projects have you words on
what sorts of things have you supplied
loads of stuff it's quite weird actually
the number of places old computers and
old because we it's more than just
computers so we supply old TVs it's just
old tech fax machines phones any
anything you know so it's you know
Christmas everything gets a bit
nostalgic so a lot of the big
supermarkets come to us and want old
things to show those old scenes of old
family life I keep saying old and it's
not
the race of one is ready player one
first person to find the egg will
inherit half a trillion dollars we
supply there lots of stuff to them
actually not so much computers but tons
and tons of software games packages and
things so they kind of wipe this out
nearly of software as far as I'm aware
and I haven't even seen it yet just kind
of implemented our archive as part of
our ology possibly so that will be
interesting to see can't wait to go see
that but but yeah this quite a few films
Eddie the Eagle and old TVs in and yeah
whenever they might want somebody
interacting with the computer then we
might supply the Machine spec it I'll
tell them what kind of machine they
would have had and then maybe write some
software that allows the actor just to
basically do that and and it come up
with whatever the script requires so we
have a box called code like a boss it's
basically just an Arduino in a box with
a serial port so we can connect into old
terminals and whatever is required of
the actor they do that and perfect
perfectly-formed C code appears on the
screen or or a letter to the president I
don't know whatever just appears
well then exactly so at the moment it's
in Hackney of the minute onset so no but
but we could do maybe we could do
another video about that later it's just
an Arduino it's nothing clever but it's
good fun what's the weirdest thing or
the wackiest thing that you've been
asked for and he provided here we've
been asked for edible paper clips which
which is interesting I don't think they
really looked at the website to see what
we did but we get the we get asked for a
dentist chairs and completely while
weird and wonderful stuff but actually
on more of a computer on topic for those
that do actually read the website we
well we're currently being asked for
what I thought was 50 IBM pcs from a
phone call you've just overheard he's
now 60 and we couldn't even do the 50
let alone the 60 so I don't know what's
going on there so yeah but that best fun
you know we it's really hard to do we've
we've got about 18 machines here that we
can
but yeah we've done what we do for the
rest we don't have to wear that one out
what's the trickiest part of it is it is
it finding the things is it making them
work what's the trickiest thing about
this industry timing
they have everything's wanted tomorrow
that's a problem yeah I think the
machines themselves through I mean we
everybody's well aware of how reliable
the machines are or maybe so we have to
make sure they know that but that means
us then maybe if they want one machine
they'll have to we'll have to have a
backup in some way because actually if
you're on set and you're you're shooting
that could be 50 people their time is
all held up by this thing not doing what
it's supposed to be doing that doesn't
go down very well so so generally
speaking we try and have in a second
machine even if you can't do a second
machine just another way of doing it
just a back-up plan might be a different
machine and done in a different way but
as long as that shot it's done that day
that's all that matters so we have to
work in those kind of it's all good
pressured but it's it's got to happen
but that's actually the good fun of it
you've got a whole bunch of people that
are there whatever happens that day
those shots will all be gone and
everybody has a very much of a can-do
attitude like Prachanda this let's try
another way let's do this and let's work
out a way I really enjoy that but but
yeah I think for the machines themselves
it's just those little things where they
say could it just do this you know can
we get you know all the colors in the
rainbow on this machine
no it's an 8-bit machine it does eight
and that's it yeah oh really we wanted
to show a photo so yeah and look do you
have to temper people's expectations
that way in terms of what would have
been possible though yes we've all seen
those programs on TV where they go bring
up the CCTV no enhancer we try and make
sure that at least the person we're
talking to in the first place is aware
of what is and what is impossible and
actually we we end up consulting on that
basis anyway in the first place but the
thing is there's more than one person
involved so as it ends up there on the
line we do get some interest and
requests onset and upset people when it
can't quite do what they want the nice
thing about it is that I suppose go back
to when I was less than 10 probably so
70s
this is embarrassing I I used to have a
cardboard box with a screen cut out of
it and a cardboard box with a keyboard
cuts out of it
and I used to pretend that I had a
computer because I didn't you know I
didn't get once in about 1980
yeah of course it's part of the
collection no I don't still have it I
don't have a picture or anything you
didn't take pictures back there did you
really it was you took pictures your
holidays you didn't take pictures of
everyday life no I don't but but the
ironic part is that you know mountain 48
no basically doing the same thing you're
still pretending with those machines and
it's actually really good fun so when
you've got a machine there and then you
you write something fairly simple stuff
you write some code to put up other than
latest when it's kind of a spy
number-crunching thing coming up on the
screen it's great fun you know it
doesn't have them work it's not really
doing anything it's just what it looks
like and then in the background of the
film you've got this thing just ticking
over it might not even be focused but
you know that you know what you did to
do it yeah getting paid to do things
that don't really actually work but they
look good the other one I suppose we
forgot about my chromium which is one of
the only ones we don't that was
fantastic
and again you know you're just writing
these little routines and things that
reflect what was going on in science a
simple little graph drawing programs and
stuff and actually some of this stuff
you do and actually quite a lot of it
sometimes doesn't even make it on the
film anyway so the computer might be
just there but the cameras pointing just
here and all that works for nothing but
but you were in microphone as well
weren't ya yeah it was some so I worked
hard on that film really hard and just
giving it all the time I could I think
any haircut for a little while and then
one day when they were at the Museum and
we were choosing bits and pieces to have
around they said oh you've got kind of
70s looking here you ought to be in the
film I ignored the the remark and but
but yeah of course we're going to want
to be in it
pair of gardening gloves so yeah there's
no bit part in the acorn scenes
technically I kind of played David
Johnson Davies but they didn't credit me